oh
[Musique]
c'est un nouvel et en fait ça consiste
donc à faire passer le scrotum dans
l'amour et pour faire remonter les
testicules eux au niveau du pubis il
faut le porter 15 heures par jour tous
les jours ça soit un slip à nano ou une
fabrication maison où on colle les
testicules à la peau ou les remonte
c'est le même effet c'est de bloquer la
spermatogénèse mais il faut savoir que
soient les dernières études qui a été
republié donc c'est des nombre de
patients qui sont pas très élevées 1
c'est une cinquantaine une soixantaine
'l'indice de perth de la notte remixé 0
5% puis les faibles plus la méthode de
contraception et efficace la vasectomie
qui les méthodes donc la plus efficace
mais qui est irréversible et à 0 1%
la pilule des femmes ces héros de 0 3%
tant qu une grande étude internationale
n'a pas validé l'efficacité définitive
de cette méthode on peut être un petit
peu sur la réserve mais a priori c'est
une méthode qui réversible et qu'un
indice de pinces très faible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et des études de phase en face d'eux
qu'ils sont déjà faits on est déjà en
train d'étudier le sait ces combinaisons
d'hormones en perros donc par la bouche
chez les as ça va faire l'objet d'une
diffusion probablement mondial dans pas
très longtemps et donc probablement
qu'on aura affaire aux mêmes effets
secondaires et peut-être à la même
réticence de la part des hommes que les
femmes ont eu plus que les femmes ont 40
ans d'histoire avec la pilule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces domaines contre ces actions qui est
efficace parce que ce fameux indice de
pearl
il n'est que de 1%
[Musique]
la vasectomie c'est forcément
irréversible mais aujourd'hui en france
on a l'obligation légale de proposer
systématiquement une crise conservation
du sperme et il existe des méthodes
chirurgicales au microscope qui
permettent de recoudre les canaux
déférents donc ces fameux canaux qui
amènent des spermatozoïdes au canoë
accumulateur mais c'est une méthode qui
est complexe qui est délicate mais qui
vend tuellement peut fonctionner alors
la méthode dure votre et qui consiste
donc à acculer à l'extérieur donc
d'interrompre son rapport sexuel dans
les faits quand on regarde les études il
ya 25% de grossesse non désirée avec
cette méthode donc c est une méthode qui
n'est vraiment pas efficace